Okay,
so we'll continue with our union
analysis of the lion king today.
We ended at the point where you remember
Mufasa had taken Simba up to the top of
pride rock and
described to him the fact that his
kingdom essentially constituted
everything that the light touched.
You can think about that as the domain
of the roughly speaking of the great
father with the domain of the great
mother on the outside of that,
that being symbolically equivalent to
the underworld or to death or to nature.
All of those things seem to be
approximately equally true and he
forbade Simba from going to investigate
what was beyond the confines of the
light and in some sense that's exactly
what a tradition does for you.
It because the tradition is precisely
what defines the domain of the light and
to be moral from the perspective of the
tradition.
It's akin to playing a Piagetian game,
but only adhering to the rules.
You know how Piaget described the fact
that when kids first master a game,
they learn,
they learn how to act it out,
and then they learn what the rules are
and then they regard the rules in some
sense as sacred.
You can't go outside the rules and then
later in moral development,
if they get to that stage,
then they start to recognize themselves
also as formulators of the rule or
formulators of the game.
And culture tells you don't go beyond
the rules.
That's the definition of morality within
the box of culture and you don't go
outside of that.
And so that's why move Fossa plays that
particular role and it's wise because if
you go outside the domain of what you
already understand that it's dangerous
out there.
Clearly it's dangerous out there.
But the downside of that particular
message,
and this is perhaps this is the
mythological reason why move Fossa isn't
as aware as he could be of scar.
You know,
his knowledge is bounded and he's not
aware enough of what lies outside of
that.
In this realm,
let's say,
of death and destruction.
And so,
um,
scar is,
he is able to overcome his,
his,
uh,
brother,
one.
You see this sort of thing happening to
people very frequently,
for example,
who develop posttraumatic stress
disorder and one of the things that's
not as well known about posttraumatic
stress disorder as might be known as a,
it happens to you if you encounter an
experience that sort of blows out the
axioms of your knowledge system,
that that's one way of looking at it.
It's so unexpected that you can't
account for it within the confines of
the,
of the system that you're using to
interpret the world.
Not often happens to people when they
encounter something that's truly
malevolent and that can be within them
or it can be in the form of someone else
who is genuinely out to hurt them.
They're often people who develop ptsd
often but not always somewhat naive and
they're are not aware of the full
catastrophe of the world.
That might be one way of looking at it
and then they encounter someone who's
truly out to hurt them and they can
detect that even in the way the person's
face looks or they encounter a part of
them that's much more malevolent than
they had ever imagined it could possibly
be.
And then they do something terrible and
then they don't know what to do about
it.
So
Dell or the Canadian general wrote a
book called shake hands with the devil.
And it was about what happened to him in
Rwanda when he was stationed there as a
UN,
a warrior or a UN soldier.
And I mean dillera was not naive,
but what he encountered was truly
malevolent and it just blew them into
pieces and,
and that that's what happens.
And so there's real utility in staying
within the bounded domain.
But the problem is,
is that there may be information that's
outside of that domain that you
absolutely need to know.
And so part of the problem with being
alive is that you have to continually
determine how much you're going to
maintain your stability and how much
you're going to explore.
And you have to explore because the
stable part of you gets outdated,
but if you explore it too much or too,
uh,
to unwisely,
then you could encounter things that
flip you upside down.
It's actually one of the problems with
being high in trade.
Openness,
especially if you're also high in
neuroticism.
Because if you're open,
you're creative,
you're always looking for,
for ideas that are outside of your
current systematic way of thinking.
But if you're high in neuroticism,
so you experienced a lot of anxiety and
emotional pain and that sort of thing,
you can continually upset your own apple
cart.
Now,
the other thing that you might want to
think about,
this is really useful as far as I'm
concerned,
is you might want to think about this
politically and we've been doing a lot
of work.
I'm going to have one of my graduate
students actually come and talk to you
about the work we'd be doing on
personality and Paul and political
belief.
So what happens with political belief is
that if you're high in openness and low
in conscientiousness,
you tend to be a liberal.
The openness being the particularly
important part of that,
and if you're low in openness and high
in conscientiousness,
especially orderliness,
you tend to be a conservative.
Now it's kind of strange because
openness and conscientiousness aren't
very highly correlated,
so it's not obvious why those two traits
would combine to determine political
belief and and the relationship is
actually quite strong between
temperament and political belief if you
measure political belief
comprehensively,
but it seems to me that the fundamental
distinction,
and this is the political game,
at least along the liberal conservative
access is boils down to one thing.
It boils down to how open borders should
be compared to how close they should be
and you know,
you can see that reflected,
for example,
in the attractiveness of trump to a
large part of the general population
because he's going to close the borders,
build a wall,
and fortify the borders and
conservatives like that.
They like to have borders between things
stay tight and they don't even care if
it's state borders or political borders
or town borders or ethnic borders or
borders between ideas or borders between
sexual identities.
Conservatives like to have things stay
in the damn box where they belong,
partly because they're orderly and
partly because they're low in openness.
They don't get any real.
They're not interested in what happens
if you free up your conceptions.
All they see in that is the probability
of disorder.
Whereas liberals who are high in
openness and low in conscientiousness
slash orderliness,
they get a real charge out of letting
things out of the box so that they can
creatively interplay.
Now the issue is who's correct and the
answer is you don't know because the
environment underneath the political
landscape moves and so sometimes the
right answer is tightened up.
The borders and fortify and sometimes
the right answer is no,
no,
no.
Loosen things up because everything's
getting too static and tight and we need
more information and the dialogue that
occurs in the political landscape with
this is why dialogue is so important,
is fundamentally between these two
opposing views of borders and because
you can't say with certainty which one
is right at any given time,
an open dialogue has to maintain itself
so that the entire political state can
maneuver properly.
Along that moving line,
it's absolutely crucial.
It's really,
really,
really useful to know that people vote
their damn temperament.
It gets you.
It gives you more of an understanding,
at least in principle of your,
of those who sit on the other side of
you on the political fence and there's
been recent newspaper articles,
quite interesting.
I tweeted a couple of them about this
company in UK called Cambridge analytics
and they're using the damn big five.
They can extract out big five
information from your facebook likes.
They've got a model of every single
person in the United States,
big five personality,
and they helped trump craft political
messages right down to the level of
apartment buildings to appeal to people
based on their big five temperament and
that's all recent work.
And so one of the things that's very
interesting is we are teaching computers
to understand us so fast you can't
believe it,
and we really do risk walking into an
electronic world where you will only see
what you want to see.
I mean,
obviously the marketers are trying to do
that as fast as possible,
right?
They only want to send you ads that
you're going to be interested in because
it's expensive and foolish to send you
anything that will annoy you or that
you'll ignore.
And so the marketers are trying like mad
to map who you are.
Even by watching your eyes there.
They're trying to figure out who you are
so they can send you the right
information.
But the danger is that that'll happen.
Say in the domain of news and broader
information,
increasing this tendency for people to
be siloed in their exposure to the
external world.
It's a big sort of like each of us is
becoming a micro celebrity surrounded by
electronic sycophants who do nothing but
tell us exactly what we want to hear.
It's a real
problem.
Karl Popper,
a famous philosopher of science said
that one of the things that you should
do,
and this is akin to the jetty and view,
is you should always look for
information that contradicts your
current viewpoint.
Now,
that's painful,
right?
Because who wants their axioms?
Contradicted.
It can take you apart,
but it's the only way that you can
ensure that you're learning at the same
time that you're maintaining your
stability and that's another reason why
it's really necessary to engage in
dialogue with people that you do not
agree with because they're the ones who
will tell you things that you don't
know.
It's crew.
It's of crucial importance in the
maintenance of your own stability.
The worst thing that can happen to a
person,
no,
because there's many horrible things
that can happen to a person,
but one of the worst things that can
happen is that you find yourself in a
situation where no one is offering you
corrective feedback anymore because you
rely on the corrective feedback provided
by other people to keep yourself sane,
to keep moving in the ever changing
environment.
And if you cut yourself off from that
feedback,
then well then you end up static and
shrinking.
It's really,
it's really not good.
You get less and less competent.
You get less and less confident and the
threats outside of you loom larger and
larger.
So that's all to do with the,
uh,
you know,
the domain outside the light.
So young would also say that out in this
domain,
that sort of beyond what you understand,
that's also where you encounter the
archetypes of the collective
unconscious.
Now,
that's a really,
really complicated idea,
but what he means by that is that if
you're put outside the domain of your
competence,
you're going to start to use fantasy to
organize your world.
So I can give you an example of that.
So you,
you,
I presume most of you are old enough to
have a conscious memory of when the twin
towers came crashing down and so
everybody in the days after that was
wandering around like they were in a
daze.
And the reason they were in a daze is
because,
well,
it wasn't exactly clear what fell right
there is the physical towers fell,
but that was only a tiny bit of the
problem because those physical towers
were embedded in a network of meaning
like a very,
very sophisticated network of meaning,
but also a political network and an
economic network and a military network
and their nodes inside a very complex
system.
And so when they come crashing down,
you don't know what's come crashing
down,
right?
So when you're out there in the unknown
and wondering what's going on and
wandering around in a daze,
which is exactly what happened to
people.
And then what Bush did,
George W was immediately turned that
into a good versus evil drama instantly.
And that's an archetypal idea.
So that's when he came up with the idea
of the axis of evil,
I think that was Iran,
North Korea,
and I don't remember the other one at
the moment,
but,
but he,
he,
he immediately turned the political
landscape into a good versus evil drama.
And he said to everyone in the world
that they were either with him or
against him fundamentally.
And that was the,
that was part of the retreating into a,
I guess a more protected landscape.
That's one of the ways that human beings
deal with the encounter with a traumatic
threat.
And so the reason you meet the
unconscious and even the collective
unconscious on the border of your
knowledge is because when you hit the
border of your knowledge,
you start to use fantasy in order to
bring the newest form of order out of
the unknown so that you can start to
make sense out of it.
And that's what artists always do.
That's what they do.
And so from the union perspective,
people who are engaged in creative art
are the ones who are on the perimeter of
knowledge structures.
And so what they're doing is taking the
absolute unknown,
which would be in Rumsfeld's terms,
the unknown unknowns,
and turning them into partially known
unknowns.
That's what an artist does.
And and especially the more classical
artists who deal with mythological and
religious themes,
which was the case for art right up
until really until the late 20th
century,
they're,
they're using these mythological ideas
to sort of extend the domain of human
knowledge out beyond its current
parameters.
And so artists do that and literary
people do that and,
and dramatists do that and they help us
extend our knowledge.
Now that's where open people live.
That's another way of thinking about it.
So think about it this way.
So you're in a city and the city has
parts of it that degenerate and so you
could think about that as order
degenerating into chaos.
And then the open people who are
creative come along and they find places
in the city that have degenerated but
that still have interesting potential,
right?
And then they move in there where it's
cheap to.
And they start producing art,
they start producing galleries and then
the coffee shops move in and then the
thing starts to get civilized and then
of course the more liberal conservative
types move in.
Those would be the Yuppies,
roughly speaking.
So they're much more conservative than
the artists,
but they're still liberal compared to
the bulk of the population.
And so the more daring people move in
after the artists of civilized it.
And then after that,
you know,
then the chain stores start to move in
and soon it's completely turned into
sellers or something like that.
And then the artists have to go
somewhere else and find another place on
the boundary where they can live.
And it's a physical.
It's a physical boundary as much as a
mental boundary.
And so you,
because you think each of those
personality traits,
there's five dimensions,
each of them represent the possibility
of inhabiting a kind of niche,
right?
In ecological niche.
So if you're an extroverted person,
your niches,
the social environment,
if you're an introverted person,
the niches,
I think nature,
I don't know that for sure because I've
never figured out exactly what
introverts are adapted to,
but it's not exactly the social world.
If you're agreeable,
then your niche is relationships.
If you're disagreeable your niches,
competition,
if you're conscientious,
you're niche niches,
duty and effort,
and so
those niches are partly social because
so much of her environment is social,
but they're also partly natural because
our social being is nested inside the
natural world and so you can think about
the big five traits as different kinds
of adaptations to different kinds of
niches and the niche that the open
people,
the open exploratory types occupy,
so that seems to make a higher order
super factor.
Extraversion and openness called
plasticity as opposed to stability,
which is conscientiousness,
agreeableness and emotional stability
and there's a playoff between those two
things because the stable people
obviously are stable,
but the plastic types of people are more
dynamic and they're more concerned with
transformation.
And in order to get a system optimally
stable and dynamic,
you have to have a continual interplay
of those,
of those factors because static doesn't
work because everything changes.
That's the problem with conservatism.
And the problem with liberalism
fundamentally is yes,
everything changes,
but you have to bring forward some
structures from the past.
So it's very,
it's very,
very difficult to get that balance
correct.
So,
all right,
so anyways,
out there in the underworld,
in the place beyond your current
conceptualizations,
that's the place of death and nature and
it's beyond the light and it's also the
place of hell.
And that's what you see here.
And what do you,
how do you conceptualize that?
Well,
one of the things you'll see if you're
interested in this sort of thing,
if you ever go read the writings of the
Columbine killers that the teens,
they're very interesting.
They're very much worth reading,
especially,
I think it's Dylan Klebold who was the
more literate of of the two,
but he tells you exactly where he went
after brooding and brooding and brooding
on his,
his isolation and segregation from
mankind.
So he's out there beyond,
he's out there in a chaotic domain and
because he's tortured by that,
his thoughts taken unbelievably dark
turn,
like it's unimaginably dark if you're
interested in that sort of thing.
You could read that.
There's another book you could read
called Pans,
Ram p a and zed r a m,
and it's a fascinating book.
It's about this guy who I think he raped
1200 men.
So that sort of tells you what sort of
guy.
He was extraordinarily physically
powerful and brutal and malevolent,
and he was kind of a juvenile delinquent
type and they put them in a reform
school and he was not well treated in
that reform school.
It's sort of like the worst of the
Canadian residential schools.
And when he came out he was not a happy
boy.
And so he spent the rest of his life
trying to be as destructive as he could
possibly imagine and purely consciously
with malevolent intent.
And then,
and,
and believe me,
he was pretty destructive.
He kept track of the dollar value of all
the buildings.
He burned down.
He tried to start a war between Britain
and the United States.
He was an all out for all out may Hamp,
his dying words that they are going
gonna hang him.
He told the guy who was going to hang
him too.
He said,
hurry up you who's your bastard?
I could kill 12 men in the time it takes
you to hang me,
and that's exactly the sort of person he
was and he made friends with this
physician in the in the prison who he
thought was the first person who ever
did something nice for him,
gave him a dollar for cigarettes,
if I remember correctly,
and the physician encouraged him to
write his autobiography and so we did
and it's available and so if you want
view,
because you know you always think of
people,
you think,
well,
people have good intentions.
You know that you especially think that
if you're naive and agreeable,
so all of you who are sitting there out
there thinking people have good
intentions,
you're probably high in agreeableness,
but that's not always the case.
People can have very dark motivations
that are fully conscious and very well
elaborated and pans around was no,
he was smart and his book is very well
written and he tells you exactly why he
thought the way he thought and so it's a
good glimpse of exactly this sort of
thing where you can get to if you want
to buy brooding on your specific
misfortune.
You know,
in his.
His basic credo was that human beings
were so reprehensible that they should
just be eliminated and believe me,
that's what he was trying to do and
these people who do terrible things like
the columbine shooters.
That's exactly what for block of a
better word they're possessed by it's
sheer malevolence and the columbine kids
had a much more spectacular catastrophe
planned than the one that actually
occurred and they knew it was going to
be a full blown media circus and lots of
these people who engage in those sorts
of mass murders.
They know about the other mass murderers
and they're engaged in a competition and
the competition is who can do the most
brutal thing the fastest.
Something like that.
So you can't just be thinking about
people who've,
who have good intentions,
but have somehow gone wrong.
If you ever meet someone who isn't like
that and you think that you're just a
tree with ripe fruit to be plucked,
so you don't want to be in that
situation.
You have to keep your eyes open.
And so anyways,
that's basically what's encapsulated in
this part of the story.
Now the hygienists go after the little
lie and obviously,
but they managed to escape it's very
malevolent scene and a move fossa shows
up at the last minute to rescue them.
So,
and you know that there's also a
mythological trope there,
which is that if you go outside your
domain of competence and you encounter
something you don't understand,
the first thing that you're going to do
is look to the knowledge structures that
you already possess to explain it.
Right?
And that's the,
you could say from a symbolic
perspective that that's the
manifestation of the father because of
course that's what you're going to do.
And you know what's really interesting
too,
is because I've had a lot of clients
who've had ptsd and and without
exception,
every single one of them was induced by
one form of malevolence or another.
They have to develop a very
sophisticated philosophy of good and
evil to get out of it because they have
a worldview in which those things don't
really exist.
There's no such thing as pure
malevolence.
Well,
that's fine unless you encounter it,
and then as soon as you encounter it,
as soon as you encounter it,
you won't know what to do and then you
won't be able to get on with your life.
You'll do nothing but think about that
and think about it and think about it
and think about it.
It'll disrupt your sleep.
It'll put you into a permanent state of
preparation for action because the part
of your brain that's detected that which
in my estimation by the way,
is the same part,
at least in part that detects snakes.
It's the same damn circuit.
Once it's seen something like that,
it is not going to let you go until you
figure it out.
And that's basically what post traumatic
stress disorder is and you know,
to some degree,
each of you will have experienced that.
Maybe not all of you in here,
but many of you and you can tell that.
So if you go back and you think about
your past and you have any memory that's
more than about 18 months old,
and when you think about it,
it produces a fair bit of negative
emotion.
Then that's like a.
that's like a place where there's a mini
posttraumatic stress problem.
And what's happened.
You remember I showed you that hierarchy
moving from tiny motor actions all the
way up to high order abstractions.
Well you can imagine,
say you have good personnel at the top
and you kind of use that scenario to
construe other people.
People are basically good.
Well then you run into someone who is
not good and boom,
the whole bloody system comes tumbling
down because it's violated that highest
order axiom.
So that's posttraumatic stress disorder.
If something has violated an axiom
that's more differentiated,
you know,
closer to the actual motor output,
not quite so high in the abstraction
chain,
then all it does is wipe out that part
of the structure.
It doesn't wipe out the whole thing and
you can tell if you have holes in your
perceptual value structure by checking
to see if you have memories that are
still alive in a negative way that are
old enough so that they should have been
incorporated into your personality and
so one of the things you can do,
you're doing one of the exercises that's
on myself authoring site.
You guys do the personality analysis,
but there's another program there called
the.
It's called the past authoring where you
write down an autobiography and thinking
through these things that have happened
to you in your past that are negative is
a good way of making them go away and
thinking them through.
Kind of means you have to figure out
what happened,
right?
And then you sort of have to figure out
how to make it not happen again.
What you're trying to derive is some
kind of causal analysis.
How is it that I was put into a
situation where I was made vulnerable,
you know,
and that could be well because you're
only four and you couldn't protect
yourself and now it's time to update
that because you're a fully functioning
adult or there may be things that you
have to think through and change in your
own personality or attitudes that you've
been holding onto since you were tiny.
I had this client once and she came in
and told me that she had been sexually
assaulted by her older brother and she
told me the story and I kind of got the
impression that maybe she was like eight
and he was like 17 or something like
that.
If she was about 27 when she came and
talked to me and then I found out by
further questioning that she was four
and he was six and I thought she still
had this story in her head of her being
tormented by this older person.
Right.
That that's how she told the story and
what I told her was,
well look,
another way of looking at this is that
youtube were very badly supervised.
Children,
because I mean he was six for God's
sake,
you know,
he's a little kid.
That doesn't mean that what happened to
her was any less traumatic but,
but he wasn't 17,
right?
The story was different than the one she
had in her head and you know,
by the time she left,
after we had that conversation,
it was clear that the way that she was
considering the experience had radically
shifted.
And it's very interesting because you
know,
you think of the past as fixed but,
and it is in some sense,
but the reason you remember the past
isn't to make an objectively accurate
record of the past.
It's so that you can use the information
in the past to prepare you for the
future and your mind won't leave you
alone unless that has happened.
So if you've encountered something
that's negative and you don't know why
and you don't know what to do about it,
if that happens again in the future,
then that will stay with you.
And I think one of the things that does
too is it increases your overall
physiological load is actually
physiologists who'd been talking about
this.
I can't remember the damn phrase,
but you could imagine that your mind is
doing something like this all the time.
It's,
it's,
it's got a record in some sense of your
autobiographical experiences and what
it's doing is calculating how frequently
you've been successful versus
unsuccessful,
and the more frequently that you've been
successful,
the higher you are up on the dominance
hierarchy.
That's one possibility.
So your serotonin levels go up and
you're calmer,
but also it's reasonable to assume that
the environment is less dangerous,
right?
Because that's sort of what constitutes
danger.
You're somewhere in react and something
you don't want to have happen happens.
That's danger.
And so your brain is always trying to
figure out how to calibrate how anxious
you should be.
And one of the things that does is by
sort of keeping track of your past
success failure ratio.
And so to the degree that your past has
been characterized by,
we'll call them failures.
Those are situations where you do not
get what you want.
Then your body,
your brain puts your body on constant
alert because if everything that you've
done has resulted in catastrophe,
then you're somewhere insanely dangerous
and you should be like like a like a
prey animal that's ready to dark in any
direction and how much you should be a
prey and I'm always dependent on it's an
estimate,
partly your trait,
neuroticism,
partly your,
your success as adjudicated by other
people,
right?
Because they'll talk pop you up the
dominance hierarchy if you've been
successful,
but also partly on your record of
failures and successes in the past and
so you can go back and you can find out
where you have holes in your,
in the structure through which you're
viewing the world.
That's one way of looking at it and you
can sell those things up and that's a
very.
That's in some sense,
that's what you're doing in
psychotherapy.
You know,
partly it's exposure to things you're
afraid of and disgusted by it are likely
to avoid.
That's a huge chunk of it,
but if you go back into your past and
you start talking those things through,
it's really the same thing.
It's more abstracted,
so Freud of course was always when he
was doing his sprit association,
a process with his clients,
he'd find that if he just let them talk,
that their speech would circle until it
hit a place like that where they were
confused and doubtful and then their
speech would sort of wander around that
and and then they'd have an emotional
expression that was a consequence of
that.
He thought the emotional expression was
what was curative.
It was cathartic in his terms,
but later James Pennebaker,
upon whom these writing exercises I
described,
his research is based on that.
My re,
my exercises are based on his research.
He found that if you brought college
students into the to the lab and you had
them write for 15 minutes,
three times over three days,
about the worst thing that had ever
happened to them or the worst thing they
ever did.
If I remember correctly,
they got worse in the short term,
but better in the long run.
For example,
I went and visited the doctor less and
markers of their physical health
improved and so I think the reason for
that is because,
what is that called?
It's called something load.
Just devoted.
Got It right from the physiologists.
It doesn't matter.
They got healthier as far as I can tell,
because they basically calmed down once
they had gone through the negative
memory and sorted it out properly and
told a properly articulated story and
figured out how to deal with it.
Then their physiology calmed down.
Um,
and so then they weren't as stressed.
They weren't producing as much cortisol
and so cortisol suppresses your immune
function and so they were more likely to
stay healthy and so well.
So that's all very much we're thinking
about.
That's all in the domain outside of the
light.
That's one way of thinking about it.
Now,
of course,
Simba and his.
And what's the girl's name?
Milo.
Yeah.
They're pretty cowed about what has
happened because they sort of stumbled
stupidly out into the unknown.
They stumbled foolishly out into the
unknown and this actually highlights
another young Ian archetype,
and that's the archetype of the
trickster and the trickster is like the
joker in the king's court and the
trickster is someone who will be or play
the fool.
And the thing about the fool is that the
full is close to the truth because you
can't learn anything new unless you're
willing to be a fool,
right?
You know what that's like.
You,
you know exactly what that's like.
Your you have to master a new skill,
but you're avoiding it because you know
that you'll be bad at it when you first
do it,
and if you're perfectionistic,
you're gonna say,
well,
I cannot allow myself to be bad at
anything.
I can't allow myself to be a fool and no
wonder,
but the problem is is when you try
something new,
you're always a fool,
and so unless you're willing to be a
fool,
you can't learn anything new,
and that's also why you regard the
trickster as the precursor to the
savior.
Archetypically speaking is because you
cannot do the right thing unless you're
willing to be a fool first and that's
really worth knowing.
Lots of times you,
you guys are gonna,
make a stage transition in your life and
you're going to feel like an imposter
when you get a new job or when you get a
promotion or something like that,
you're going to feel like an imposter
and you are because what do you know
when you make that first transition,
right,
but it's gonna make you embarrassed and
it's gonna make you ashamed and all of
those things,
but you have to understand that you are
a fool when you first try something new,
but you're a worst fool if you don't try
it and that doesn't mean you should make
like you know everything.
As soon as you're promoted or or you
have some transition in status,
that's foolish.
Have the wrong sort.
But to know that,
to know that you have to be fallible in
order to progress,
it's an unbelievably useful thing.
It can free you up.
You know,
I was talking to a writer the other day
about his process for beginning writing.
He's written many books.
He writes a very,
very,
very bad first draft.
Right?
And that's a good way to think about
things is throughout your life you're
going to be doing that is writing the
next draft of you and it's pretty bad to
begin with,
but that's okay because it isn't going
to get any better unless you put
yourself out into the domain of the
unknown to begin with.
And you know,
you might,
it might go badly.
I mean that's what happens here.
Anyways,
mythos that has a chat with Simba and
tells them that he's.
He did what he wasn't supposed to do.
Although,
you know,
even in that situation with FAA says,
discipline is paradoxical because
there's part of him because he's
reasonably.
Why's that knows that breaking the rules
like that is actually necessary.
Even though you still have to say play
by the damn rules,
you know,
you have to leave that door open so that
the rules can be broken and appropriate
amount.
So he forgives him and pieces made
between them and then
they're there,
they involve themselves in sort of
gazing at the night sky,
and so the two of them do that together
and the night skies and interesting
place,
you know,
because that's where the absolute
unknown resides.
One of the things you wrote a lot about
was astrology,
strangely enough slash astronomy and one
of young's contentions.
This is a very interesting one,
was that because of the night sky was
completely unknown.
People could project their fantasies
into it and that's what they did with,
with astrology.
So astrology is this cumulative fantasy
that's going on in that roughly speaking
in the deep unconscious,
projected onto the sky.
And so if you analyze old astrological
writings,
what you're really doing is analyzing
old fantasies.
And because of that you could develop
some insight into the structure of the
mind.
And so he did the same thing with
alchemy in his later writings,
which are very,
very difficult to understand,
but extremely worthwhile.
Okay.
So anyways,
back to the,
to the hellish domain.
Now I told you that that domain,
that's of knowledge,
you could think about that as the
underworld or you can think about it as
nature,
the negative element of nature in
particular,
and so I mentioned that one element of
that is hellish and that's exactly what
the movie explains next does exactly
that.
We go back out to this domain that scar,
the adversary or the negative king.
Now that's another way of looking at
him.
This is his,
his,
the domain over which he rules and so
you can see them.
They're surrounded in fire.
Same idea as the hyenas surrounded by
fire earlier.
All this green fire and smoke,
which I think is even worse,
and this is where the movie starts to
draw on essentially Nazi symbolism,
at least the symbolism of totalitarian
states and you know,
you think about,
you think about a totalitarian state,
you think about the Nazis and their
goosestepping.
What's happening is that every single
person in the military becomes an
identical unit,
right?
A unit.
They're all uniform and they're all in
some sense imitating the the dictator
and in an absolutely perfect way and so
the dictator wants to impose strict
uniformity on the entire population
that's order order and one of the things
we've discovered that's really
interesting is that
disgust sensitivity is associated with
orderliness and that's associated with
conscientiousness and one of the things
about Hitler was that he was very
disgust sensitive and a lot of his
hatred for non Ariens,
so imagine inside the area and box.
It was all uniform outside.
It was all parasites and predators and
so and that was a manifestation of
disgust,
not a fear.
It's a whole different thing.
And if you read Hitler's table talk,
which is a collection of his spontaneous
dinner speeches from 1939 to 1942.
It's a very interesting book.
You see that his metaphor for the area
and race was a body of pure body on
assaulted by parasites are predators and
that he was trying to erect a border
around it to keep all of that away.
So it's an immunological discussed like
metaphor and there's some recent work
that was published in Plos one about
three years ago showing that brilliant
study should have got much more
attention showing that if you went
around and sampled political attitudes
in different countries or even within
the same country,
what you found was that the higher the
prevalence of infectious diseases,
the higher the probability of
totalitarian political attitudes at the
local level.
And you can imagine,
well what happens if there's infectious
diseases is you want to put borders
around everything.
You don't want free movement between
ideas or people because that's partly
how the disease spreads.
You're going to have much more strict
sexual rules,
for example,
because that's a great way for diseases
to be transmitted.
And before Hitler went on his rampage
against the non Ariens,
he'd cleaned up all the factories.
Like he went in there and fumigated
them.
It was part of the law and he went on a
public health campaign to get rid of
tuberculosis.
And he got rid of the bugs in the
factories as well.
He used Zyklon B,
that's an insecticide,
and now it's the gas that he used in the
gas chambers eventually.
So first it was the bugs and the rats
and that it was people who were that it
was euthanasia.
That was the next move and forest you
euthanasia and the rationale for that
was compassion,
by the way,
just so you all know,
it's,
it's merciful to put these people who
are burdened some to themselves and
their families around the state who are
living second grade lives.
It's merciful to euthanize them,
and that was a huge campaign in Germany.
It was after that that the more racial
purifications began,
and so that's the disgusting.
That's unbelievably important.
It's,
it's,
it's because lots of times people think
that conservatives are more anxiety
sensitive than liberals and that's why
they're closed in terms of their ideas.
That doesn't look right.
First of all,
conservatives are less neurotic than
liberals,
although the effect isn't that big,
so it doesn't look and they actually
are.
They score higher in measures of
wellbeing.
The most unhappy people are liberal men
by the way,
so
but you know,
people are often accused if they're
conservative,
of being fearful and that's why they
suppress other people's viewpoints,
but that doesn't look right.
It's low openness and high orderliness
and that looks like it's associated with
disgust and that looks like it's
associated with something called the
extended immune system,
which is the proclivity of people to to
keep themselves away from potential
sources of contamination.
It's really terrifying because one of
the things people often said about
Germany was that it was a very civilized
country and yet it descended into
barbarity.
Conscientiousness is a very good
predictor of long term success and so
you could say,
well conscientious societies are more
civilized,
but they're also more orderly and that
makes them more disgust sensitive.
And so what it might have easily might
have easily been in Germany was that it
was an excess of civilization rather
than its lack that produced exactly
these consequences and that's a far more
frightening proposition.
And one that's I believe,
much more likely to be true.
Hitler based four times a day and he was
also an admirer of willpower so he could
stand like this for eight hours in the
back of a car,
and the thing about conscientious people
is they're very willpower oriented and
so if you're unfortunate enough to be
sick chronically in the house of someone
who's conscientious,
especially if it's a mental illness,
you're more likely to relapse because
the conscientious person is going to be
judgmental and they're going to say to
you,
if your schizophrenia,
they're gonna say,
well,
if you just organize yourself and get up
in the morning and try a little harder,
you could overcome this,
which is of course true,
except you can't because you're
schizophrenic and so the pressure put on
you by the anger and the contempt is
going to increase the probability that
you'll relapse.
So orderly.
People are very judgmental and you know,
orderliness is a very highly with things
like anorexia and the anorexic is
basically someone who's so disgust
sensitive that they become unable to
tolerate their own body and they see it
as a source of corruption and
imperfection,
which of course is exactly right.
It is and it's very difficult thing to
maintain order around.
So anyways,
so what happens out here in this
terrible domain where scar rules is that
thing's turned into a totalitarian
state,
you know,
and he's,
he's presented here as,
as a Nazi,
like leader and see.
There's another thing that's really
interesting to see even deeper than this
from a mythological perspective.
I don't know if I can even go into it.
Well,
not really.
I guess what I'll have to do is satisfy
myself with this observation.
There's always been some antagonism,
for example,
between the Catholic Church and
rationalism and everyone knows that it's
a very long standing antagonism that
sort of runs its way through at least
the last thousand years or so of Western
civilization and the people who regarded
Catholics as antithetical to science,
take the Catholics to task for that in
describing it as prejudicial and super
superstitious and fair enough,
but there's something else going on
there that's more important.
And that's the observation and this is
at a deep level,
again,
the observation that rationality has one
big problem,
so it's,
it can easily become arrogant and
believe in.
It's own theories,
so if you're smart and you're going to
be some of you people who are like that
too,
some of you,
your primary,
the primary trait that distinguished you
from other people over the course of
your whole life was that you are more
intelligent than most and you may have
staked your identity on that and and
overvalue intelligence and rationality,
and the problem with that is that you
make a theory of the world and then you
tend to assume that it's 100 percent
correct.
That's the tendency to fall in love with
your own theories and that's what a
totalitarian does.
The totalitarian says,
here's the Damn theory and it's exactly
right and you're gonna.
Act it out.
Exactly,
and if you don't,
well,
we've got some special treats in mind
for you and one of the most terrible
things that I encountered while reading
about totalitarianism and this was even
more true of the Soviet Union under it,
was that the true believers and they
were,
many of them
were in a terrible position because
according to their own doctrine,
they're already involved in the process
that was going to bring utopia to
mankind.
The problems had already been solved,
but many of them were still suffering
terribly as individuals,
but if you're a totalitarian believer in
utopia,
your own suffering becomes heretical.
Right?
Because your suffering is an indication
that the damn theory isn't correct,
and so then you're in a terrible
position because you either admit that
the theory isn't correct and fall apart
because of that and maybe face terrible
punishment as well.
Or you have to separate yourself from
your own suffering and lie about it.
Fundamentally,
and of course that's exactly what
happened in places like the Soviet Union
where everyone lied about everything all
of the time,
to themselves,
to their family members,
to their friends.
The entire system was completely
permeated by lies and so you get this
terrible place that scars the ruler over
which is totalitarian and brutal and
murderous and resentful and deceitful
and arrogant all at the same time and
that's brought about so the columbine
guys,
for example,
when they're justifying their
murderousness and their plans to shoot
up the schools,
they keep making reference to the fact
that people had slighted them,
for example,
you know,
and insulted them and that they were
alienated.
They weren't bullied exactly the way the
press made it out.
I don't know if they were bullied
anymore than people usually are in high
school,
but they took their alienation
personally and regarded that their
isolation from common humanity as
indication of the pathology of
everything,
and then they went out to destroy and
that's exactly what this sort of thing
represents.
Now it's the uniformity and you see he's
got this kind of vicious grin on his
face which is malicious and pleased all
at the same time.
There is no fear in that.
It's quite quite the opposite
and there's another image of using
what's essentially imagery of hell,
which everyone understands strangely
enough,
and that associates him with the
crescent moon.
The crescent moon is.
Well,
it's a symbol of darkness and the
underworld fundamentally.
So.
Alright,
so anyways,
so that's we see the underworld,
we see that which lies beyond the light.
And in there we see a fragment of that
that's basically hellish and all of
that's incorporated into the story.
And everyone understands that when they
see it even without,
I would say the overt references to
Nazi-ism okay,
so now scar has a plan.
He's going to kill the king and he's
going to do that by putting what the
king loves in danger.
Scar feigning.
Sympathy has enticed Simba down into
this ravine and scars.
Minions are going to cause a willdabeast
stampede,
right?
So a mindless stampede to,
to,
uh,
to put,
to put him in danger.
And so that's what happens here.
The old buddies start to march into the
ravine and everyone is making a scar,
tells Mufasa that Simba is down in that
ravine and entices them down there.
And so they're all off running to see if
they can save Simba and then you see
mythos of running in front of the
willdabeast,
heard,
trying to,
trying to find a son and and trying to
stay ahead of them.
The mad mob that's put his son in
danger.
And so he tries to escape climbing up
the Butte,
which is almost a sheer cliff and when
it gets to the top,
his brother is waiting for him there and
he asks him to pull them up and scar
basically before he kills them,
indicates that he's betraying him and
puts his claws into move us,
pause and throws them off the cliff.
And so that's that.
And it's a sad part of the story.
It's a part that's very hard on kids
because the father has died and you
know,
it's a rare kid who won't cry about that
scene in particular where you see Simba
very upset and his father dying.
Now this is a hard part of the story to
interpret and the.
I don't know if it's because of my lack
of ability to interpreter because the
story takes a weird twist here.
But there,
there is this confusion in the story
about whether symbols and innocent
victim who set up for the murder of his
father or whether he actually bears some
guilt for it,
you know,
and he's broken some rules and that and
and so on.
So he's not exactly placed in the
position of innocence,
but of course he's also been set up by
scar in any case,
scar tells him that it's his fault,
pure and pure,
and that because of that,
he's going to have to leave.
He's going to have to be banished beyond
the kingdom.
Now
you see this motif quite quite
frequently and hero stories where the
hero has to be raised outside of the
kingdom.
That happens with King Arthur for
example,
and it happens with Harry Potter because
Harry Potter is raised by muggles
instead of being inside the magic
kingdom.
So it's a very common theme.
And partly what it means is that it
means two things.
One is that you do grow up alienated
from your culture to some degree.
There's no way around that because the
culture doesn't match you perfectly and
it doesn't work for you perfectly.
And it's old and it's kind of corrupt
and it alienates you as it's shaping
you,
and so you're going to develop some
separation from it.
And you see that in intergenerational
rhetoric.
You know,
where the new generation has the
proclivity to blame the previous
generation for everything that's wrong
with the current system.
And Fair enough,
you know,
because you do inherit everything that's
wrong.
Of course you also inherit everything
that's going well,
which is a good thing to also notice,
but the idea is that you can't help but
be alienated from,
let's call it the patriarchy for,
for lack of a better word because it's
got a tyrannical element and because
it's not matched well to you.
So,
but then there's also this other issue
which is,
well,
maybe you're not being successful by the
terms that are by the values that are
instantiated in the current system.
And you might say,
well,
that's because the system is set up in
an unfair manner and fair enough,
but it's also possibly because you're
just not very good at acting out those
values.
Right?
So part of the reason you get alienated
from your culture is because culture is
corrupt,
but another part of the reason is you're
just not doing as well as you could be.
You're not playing by the rules,
even your own rules properly and so you
get alienated and you're unsuccessful
because of your own inadequacies.
And so the movie plays both of those.
It's obviously Simba is set up,
but there is an intimation that he's not
entirely blameless as well.
Anyways,
he's very broken up about this and no
wonder it's also partly a story of the
emergence of adolescence because you
know when you're a child and you're
ensconced right inside the familial
framework,
then you sort of exist within that
system of rules like you would under the
psg Eddie and scheme,
but when you become an adolescent,
then there's much more of a proclivity
to break free and to start breaking
rules and so that's also a canyon in
some sense to the death of the father
and as a necessary developmental stage.
Anyway,
scar comes down into the ravine.
It's all foggy now because that goes
along with sort of murkiness of death
and tells Simba that it's his fault and
that he's going to have to leave.
He's going to have to leave the kingdom
of his father,
which makes sense.
Now his father is dead.
So how are you gonna?
Once your father has died,
how are you going to stay around in his
kingdom so to speak?
So and then scar tries to get these
hyenas to go track him down and kill
them.
So
and Zuzu goes back to tell all the rest
of the lions that move.
Faa says,
Dad,
in that Simba has disappeared and then
scar takes over pride rock.
And so what's happened now is the
malevolent element of the king has
obtained control over the state,
right?
And so this is the king.
The wise king wasn't paying enough
attention.
That's one way of looking at it.
And so the malevolent part of the state
has now got control.
This is a very,
very old idea.
I've traced it back at least several
thousand years in its,
in its representation in stories.
You can see it in Egyptian mythology,
for example,
so the idea is that as the social
structure builds and complexity,
it offers you the protection of a
functioning complex system,
but it also becomes increasingly likely
to turn into a tyranny and because it's
more and more powerful,
the fact of its potential for tyranny
becomes more and more of a danger.
And so then the question is,
well,
what are the factors that encourages it
turning into a tyranny?
And one factor would be the wisest part
of it is not paying enough attention to
the malevolent part of it.
And you could say that's true at the
state level and it's also true at the
individual level,
right?
You have to watch your own proclivity to
upset yourself and other people and and
take that into account and pay careful
attention to it because otherwise it can
gain control,
especially because you're going to avoid
looking at it.
And one of the characteristics of the
wise king who gets overthrown by the
tyrant is that he has an evil brother
and he won't pay enough attention to
him.
He avoids,
he doesn't look.
And so the,
the evil king gets the upper hand and
that's what's happened here.
And so notice now he takes possession of
pride rock,
not in full daylight,
right?
But at night.
So that ties his rule into the rule of
unconscious processes in and
malevolence.
Alright?
So Simba runs away from the kingdom out
into the desert.
Now why is that?
Well,
you remember,
maybe you remember and maybe you don't.
Maybe you don't know what the story of
exodus.
When Moses takes the Hebrews out of
Egypt,
they end up in a desert.
Well,
why?
it's because when you leave a kingdom,
no matter how tyrannical,
you still fall into disorder,
you're in a place that's desert.
There's no civilization there.
No,
that's what happened to Iraq.
After the Americans went in,
you know,
the,
the Americans,
the neocons were all convinced that the
Iraqis would welcome them with open arms
and there would be this smooth
transition to democracy.
Same idea in Libya.
It's like,
no,
that's not what happens.
What happens is the state devolves into
a desert chaos and maybe then you can
make order,
but probably not.
And so Simba has left the kingdom and
the first thing that happens is he damn
near dies in the desert.
And so you know,
if you have an old belief system and
it's not working very well and you
abandon it,
well,
good for you because you're out of the
old belief system,
but now you're nowhere.
One of the things that happens to
alcoholics,
for example,
and and draw draw other drug addicts as
well.
So imagine that
you're trying to stop drinking.
All right,
fine.
Maybe you have to undergo some medical
treatment so when you first stopped,
you don't die of seizures because that
often happens to people who are addicted
to alcohol.
So when they get valium or something
like that from a doctor to see them
through the first bits of
what would you call it?
A while of sobering up and so they get
through it and then then maybe two weeks
later,
they're not physiologically dependent on
alcohol anymore.
Same thing is true of cocaine.
But if you take them back and you put
them in their environment,
say they go back out to the treatment
center,
back into the normal world,
they start drinking or using right away
again.
And the reason for that is that,
well,
let's say you've been an alcoholic for
20 years.
Okay?
First of all,
that's all you do for entertainment.
You drink,
all your friends are alcoholics,
right?
And so
if you're going to stop drinking,
not only do you have to
rid yourself of the,
of the physiological addiction,
but you have to completely learn a new
way of living because what do you know?
You have to get rid of all your friends
because they're drunks pretty much.
Or if they're not there,
at least people who are facilitating
your drinking.
So you have to build a whole new social
network.
You don't know how to amuse yourself
because of course the way you've done
that is by going to the bar or sitting
at home drinking.
And so there's a huge hole in your life.
You abandoned the previous pathological
mode of adaptation,
but that just leaves you with nothing.
And then you have to rebuild that thing
from,
from scratch.
It's extraordinarily difficult.
And that's why so many people fail when
they're trying to overcome a major
addiction.
So.
Alright.
So anyways,
symbols out there in the desert.
He's left his family and the comforts of
home and he's,
he's discovered by these by Puma and who
a little rats name to tymone yes,
he's a mere cat,
right?
Which are very cool things
and they discover them and this is sort
of his transition into adolescence and
he,
he kind of finds,
and this is,
I would say more typical of the male
transition into adolescence because
females of course hit puberty so much
younger.
The males who aren't very attractive
when they're young and just starting to
undergo puberty that are very attractive
to females.
They tend to clump together in gangs
and,
and manage the transition over what
could be seven years.
So,
and that's what happens here is Simba
joins this little gang of,
you know,
these guys are all right,
but you know,
they're a little on the primordial side
you might say,
you know,
one of them is basically just a walking
gastrointestinal tract and the other one
is,
he's not so bad,
but he's like a foot high.
Really.
What good is he?
And so he,
he's got some second rate companions out
here past the desert,
but he enters,
he's out of childhood now and now he
enters the adolescent world.
What happens here is that very quickly
in the film,
he goes from being a little cub to a
full full adolescents.
There's about a five minute transition
and so it's the next stage in his
development and now he's out there in
this paradise,
which is kind of strange because
adolescence really is no,
no picnic.
But the idea here is that he really
doesn't have any responsibilities,
right?
None.
And that is one thing about adolescence
is,
and even the stage of life that you guys
are at is you have lots to do,
but you're not really responsible for
anyone other than yourself.
And so even though you might be quite
burdened with your current
responsibilities,
it's nothing compared to what it would
be like when you know you have
responsibility for,
for children for example,
or for the people that are working for
you or or whatever.
So anyways,
out here it's a kind of impulsive place
as well.
And adolescents is like that.
We've had high school students try to do
the future authoring program,
you know,
where they have to think three to five
years down the road.
It's like forget that they just can't do
it.
And I've watched them.
And what happens is you immediately
become aware of just how little high
school students know when they're like
15 or 16,
three to five years,
forget it.
They don't have the world knowledge to
project themselves out that far in the
future,
not even close.
So we've built a high school version
that helps them design a better future.
Three to six months down the road and
even that's really pushing it,
but you know adolescents are more
impulsive and they live more for the
moment and
there's some utility anatomy.
Being impulsive and living for the
moment is one of the things that gets
you pregnant as a teenager and that is
certainly one way that the species has
managed to propagate itself and so
positive emotion and impulsivity are
very tightly linked and so he's out
there in this adolescent delusional
fantasy that might be one way of
thinking about it,
but more important he's out there where
he's in a domain now where the impulses
of the moment basically take precedence
and so and I think they sing some song
about,
yeah,
Hakuna Matata,
right?
Which basically means do whatever,
do whatever you want,
and tomorrow will take care of itself or
something like that.
So it's very impulsive and lacks all
responsibility.
One of the things that I would recommend
to you if you want to protect yourself
from ideological possession,
shall we say,
is that when you hear people speak
politically and they don't say anything
about your responsibilities,
you should probably stop listening to
them because whenever they're trying to
offer you something,
if it doesn't come along with an
equivalent cost,
there's something being hidden from you
and they're appealing to the part of
you.
That's what I would say at best
adolescent.
So.
Alright,
so anyways,
he's out there in his little adolescent
paradise and,
uh,
with his dopey chums and back at,
at pride rock.
Things are not good,
right?
Scar,
who's arrogant and refuses to learn and
who will not establish a reasonable
relationship with the females.
All he does is tyrannized over them.
He ends up ruling over a completely
barren landscape.
And that's really what happens in
totalitarian states.
And we also know quite interestingly,
is that one of the best predictors of
economic development in estate is the
degree to which they extend rights to
women.
It's one of the best predictors.
And I would say,
well,
if you're going to tear nine your own
women,
you're going to terrorize everything.
You're going to tear tyrannized ideas,
you're going to tear a nice structures
like if you have to enslave your own
women,
you're.
You've adapted a pretty damn
pathological view of the world and the
probability that that narrow,
constrained,
restricted viewpoint is going to pay off
for you economically is extraordinarily
low.
So anyways,
scar.
It's like what happened in the Soviet
Union to know.
Part of the reason it collapsed by 1989
is that it just could not move any
farther.
It was like this really complicated
motor that was worn completely out that
no one had ever taken care of and it
just ground to a halt.
It just stopped working because it
because it didn't work.
And so if you're a totalitarian and you
won't update your system and adjusted,
then it wears out and grinds a halt and
everything becomes unproductive.
Now,
it's not easy to figure out what makes
us society productive because you might
say,
well,
it's natural resources or something like
that.
First of all,
natural resources are very often a curse
to a country because they produce
corruption.
They call that the Dutch disease.
There's a reason for that.
You can look it up,
but natural resources in and of
themselves are by no means sufficient to
guarantee the wellbeing of a country.
Japan has virtually no natural resources
at all and it's really rich and one of
the prime natural resources actually
seems.
Maybe there's two.
One is honesty and other is trust and if
you can set up a society where people
are roughly honest,
which means they do what they say
they're going to do and where the
default bargaining position on both
sides is trust,
then the probability that that culture
will become wealthy is very,
very high.
So,
and a functional legal system is also a
natural resource of tremendous,
tremendous value.
You know,
it's partly why people in China,
for example,
wealthy people in China are dumping
their money into the real estate market
in North America like mad because one of
the things you do know if you buy real
estate in North America,
as you actually own it,
it's still going to be years,
20 years in the future,
30 years in the future.
There's no doubt about that.
And so that fact of ownership is
embedded in the functioning legal system
and that's what gives those sorts of
properties crazy value,
much too much to the problematic
situation for all of you people who are.
At some point,
most of you are going to try to buy
property in Toronto and that's really
going to be entertaining.
So now look the the other thing about
scars,
he's got the little Burg locked up,
right?
That's the vision of the king.
Well,
he doesn't want to know anything.
He already knows everything.
So why does he need this stupid bird
flying around telling them what's going
on?
The last thing he wants to know is
what's going on a stolen.
I mean,
God,
you gave that guy bad news or good news
he was going to have you killed.
It kept the bad news to a minimum and
that's a real problem,
right?
Because if you torture people who bring
you bad news,
then you're never going to learn
anything while you don't have to,
if you already knew everything anyways.
And so that's the situation here.
Well,
his little minions,
the hyenas are getting pretty unhappy
because they haven't had anything to eat
and the reason for that is they've just
stripped the landscape bear,
right?
I mean,
I read at the demise of the Soviet Union
that something like 10 to 15 percent of
the entire land mass of the Soviet Union
had been rendered permanently
uninhabitable by industrial pollution.
So that,
I don't remember if that included
Chernobyl,
where that terrible nuclear accident
took place,
but,
but there were massive domains of
devastation and in those countries that
will take hundreds of years to fix.
So anyways,
when scar rules,
everyone starves.
That's a good way of thinking about it
or everyone dies,
but that's okay because that's really
what he's after anyway.
So that works out quite nicely.
Now,
back out here in paradise.
I mean,
look at him.
How pathetic can you get?
Look at the expression on that
creature's face.
You know,
he's,
he's self's,
he's sated like someone who's just eat a
gallon of ice cream and he's got this
pathetic
self satisfied,
naive,
clueless unconscious grin on his face,
which the animators did a very nice job
of capturing,
like that's a complicated expression and
you just want to slap them and that's
exactly what should happen.
And that's exactly what does happen.
So anyways,
he's out there,
be an unconscious Dingbat.
Well his society is degenerating and
that's bloody well we're thinking about
because that's an archetypal trope,
right?
It's like things are sinking around you.
The question is,
what are you doing about it?
You know,
are you just staying in kind of a blithe
unconsciousness because you can get your
next meal.
Are you going to wake up and do
something about it?
Well,
that's the call of the self.
So now we go back to two Rafiki here and
he knows what's going on in the kingdom.
He's a symbol of the self.
And he also has some inkling that Simba
is still alive,
so,
so the son of the king is still alive,
despite the fact that the,
the,
the land has become ruled by a tyrant
and the sun is absent.
He still around somehow.
And so in a union from the union
perspective,
there isn't much distinction between the
self and the and the and the child.
The self is the sum total of all
possibility and the child is possibility
itself.
And so,
so let's say you've become an
adolescent,
you're all cynical,
right?
And everything's falling apart around
you,
which is the typical state of human
beings,
right?
Because adolescents are cynical,
generally speaking and everything's
falling around,
falling apart around them generally
speaking.
And so what do you have to do in order
to do something about that?
Well,
one is you have to be drawn by the call
of wisdom.
And the other part is that you have to
rediscover that part of yourself.
That's a child like part that's
associated with the sun and associated
with that early,
the early exposure of similar to the
sun.
You have to find that again.
And then trust that some child like
exploration and a bit of manifestation
of faith might get you to the next
place.
And so that's what's happening here with
the little,
you know,
the baboons in the tree and the,
and the drawing.
So anyways,
he knows that Sim was alive now and so
he goes off to find them and meanwhile
sinbad,
his dopey companions are out hunting for
bugs,
you know,
because he's a lion,
we shouldn't eat bugs for crying out
loud but they are easy.
And so you see the scene where Puma goes
after this bug and then another lion
shows up and chases him.
So she's going to kill them and eat
them.
And See.
That's an interesting thing because one
of the things that happens,
I suppose you could think about this,
one of the things that happens in late
adolescence is that the formation of
gangs is often broken up by the
proclivity of one or more members of
that gang to get involved in an
individual romantic relationship.
And so the idea that the female lion is
the carnivore female is the carnivore
that will devour the group is exactly
right.
And so what a girl will do often if
she's in a relationship with somebody
like a young man or an older adolescent,
is she'll try to separate him from his
dopey friends and like,
no wonder,
you know,
why wouldn't she do that?
Because he does have top friends and
it'd be better for him if he could get
beyond them.
And so anyways,
they're pretty freaked out about this.
And so then Simba goes out and has a
fight with this lion to protect his
dopey chums and I'm sure you don't need
any explanation about what that means.
And they have this huge fight and Nalla
who it turns out to be Pinza.
And so that goes back to the beginning
of the story where when he first
encountered her,
she pinned them all the time.
She's an anima figure,
right?
And now what she does immediately is
shame him.
So he's an figure,
in part,
she's an anima figure in part because
she actually does shame him,
right?
So she's the gateway to higher
consciousness,
she makes him self conscious and rightly
so,
but he's also a.
she's also a psychological figure
because he imagined that when a young
man is establishing a relationship with
a young woman and he's,
he's enamored of her,
he's falling in love,
he projects an ideal onto her and that
ideal is going to be partially fulfilled
by the relationship,
the degree to which is unspecified,
and sometimes it'll collapse completely,
but he projects an ideal onto her
because otherwise you wouldn't be
attracted to her.
And then the ideal judges him and so
that makes them feel all self conscious
and useless,
which is useful because he is useless
and should feel that way.
And so it's part of the impetus to
growing up.
So,
and of course one of the
you need necessity in order to mature
you because to mature is to take on
responsibility and you're not going to
feel that impetus unless
adopting the responsibility has some
sort of payoff.
And women tend to mate across and up
dominance hierarchy.
So they tend to actually like men who
are useful.
And so if they encounter a man who isn't
used full at all,
they're gonna.
That's exactly what's going to happen.
They're going to not be happy about that
in the least.
And so no wonder,
and I think the reason for that,
it's economic antibiological reason.
The reason is,
is that women are in the position of
having to take care of infants primarily
and an infant has a very heavy load and
so even a woman who's extraordinarily
competent is going to find herself
substantially limited in her
possibilities if she has an infant.
And so then she's looking around for
someone who will pick up part of the
load.
It's perfectly reasonable and you're not
going to pick up part of the load if
you're completely useless.
And so it's in the woman's best interest
not to have two children roughly
speaking.
So anyway,
she pins him and then he's all resentful
about it immediately because she's
calling him on his stupid friends and
the fact that he's out there
gallivanting impulsively in paradise
when there's real problems to be solved.
And so look at him.
He's all resentful and useless and,
and feeling put upon.
And picked upon and you just got to slap
him again,
fundamentally.
And she's just completely stunned by
that.
It's like,
and tells them,
you know,
where's the Sim by use to know right now
he's a little doubtful about the whole
situation there.
The animators do a very nice job of this
part of the movie because one of the
things you see is that his eyebrows are
always pointing up in the middle.
Whereas his father's eyebrows were
pointing down in the middle.
And so that's the difference between
this,
which is sort of like things are
happening to me and this which is more
like I'm imposing my will on things and
that's an immature face.
And,
and the automators captured that
brilliantly.
So here's where she shames him again.
She tells him how much he liked him when
he was little and,
and you know,
a potential king and how hurt she is
that he's this useless,
wide-eyed,
naive,
impulsive,
pleasure seeking adolescent.
And
she tells him that she missed him and
God only knows why.
Because look at them again.
It's like completely appalling pauling
creature and this is when Puma and sing
that song about the fact that you know,
their friends doomed because you know,
this girl's got him and then they switch
into another archetipal scene and so
they're falling in love here and so that
paradise imagery is really highlighted
in the movie and so they go off and have
this like romp self reflective romp
through this new paradise and they
wrestle around and play and then he pins
her more or less than she licks them.
That's,
that's not so good.
And this is one of the most brilliant
shots I think that the animators managed
because she's obviously pushing this a
little bit farther than he knows what to
do with.
And so they're wrestling and he,
she licks them and then she lays down
and makes this face,
which is every single class I've ever
showed this to all laugh when they see
that image.
And that's a good example.
So Freud said that jokes were a good
route into the unconscious.
So the question is,
and this is an archetypal facial
expression and everyone knows exactly
what it means.
There's something sexually seductive
about it and something very sexually
seductive about it,
despite the fact that it's a linus and
the animators do an extraordinarily good
job of capturing that.
And so that has a huge effect on him.
While these guys know that the games out
man,
it's like they know their dad,
whatever attractions they can offer our
paling in comparison to so.
So anyways,
things don't really progress passed out,
but you know,
he gets a hint of her longing for him,
what's waiting for him if he grows up
and the fact that she's completely
disappointed in him because he's so
completely useless.
And so now he's lounging about like some
basement dweller with cheeto dust all
over his chest and trying to justify his
absolutely useless life.
And you know,
saying that he doesn't have any
responsibility to the devastated kingdom
and he's out there were Hakuna Matata,
you know,
I can just do whatever I want and,
and follow my impulsive pleasures.
And she thinks he's pretty pathetic.
And the reason for that is because he is
actually pretty pathetic.
And she,
she tells him that she's extraordinarily
disappointed and he gets all pouty about
it.
I mean,
even here,
you see when he,
when he's got kind of an aggressive look
on his face,
there's still nothing about it that's
commanding.
It's petulant,
right?
It's like,
well now I'm irritated,
but he's got no force and,
and still completely appalling in this,
in this particular situation.
So she judges him very harshly and
leaves and that makes them think,
hey,
it's all self conscious because this
female that he admires wants to have
nothing to do with him.
And so he's first of all,
then he thinks,
well maybe I'll just hate all women,
which is pretty pathetic conclusion.
And,
but a very common one.
And the next is,
well maybe there's actually something
wrong with them.
Right?
Which is a very painful bit of self
reflection.
So he,
he had,
he knows that there's something wrong
with him.
And then he calls out to his father and
says,
look,
you said you were always going to be
here for me and you're not.
And so what's happening is that he's,
he's become aware of the insufficiency
of his current adolescent value
structure and he wants something beyond
it,
which would be associated with
identification with the father,
but he can't.
He can't find the father.
The father is dead.
It's like when Pinocchio goes down to
the bottom of the ocean to bring Japan
Eto up from the depths,
right?
That's the situation that that symbol
finds himself in.
Right now,
the father's gone and has to be brought
up from the depths.
So this is where the movie takes the,
they the archetypical pathway of an
initiation ceremony.
So he says he wants to change.
Now,
one of the things,
Carl Rogers,
one of the clinicians that we'll talk
about pointed out was that if,
if someone was going to come to
psychotherapy,
there's some things that had to happen
before they went into psychotherapy.
And one thing that had to happen was
that they had to admit that there was
something wrong and they had to want to
change.
You had to have that before you went
into the psychotherapeutic situation.
And what happens here is Simba is
actually,
he's dropped his arrogance and he's
looking upward,
kind of like Japan,
Eto wishing on the Star in Pinocchio.
He's looking upwards.
He looking towards something higher and
he wants to transform himself.
So he's asked the question,
how can I change for the better?
And he doesn't get an answer.
And then Rafiki shows up.
So what does that mean?
It means that as soon as you know you're
wrong about something,
as soon as you admit that you're wrong
about something and you open the door to
potential change,
that part of you will respond.
So,
and you know this because think about
this,
you're thinking so you ask yourself a
question because that's what you do when
you're thinking and then you generate
some answers.
It's like,
it's very strange.
The thinking will actually work.
You can actually come up with answers if
you think about something.
And so this credit,
this issue is okay.
I thought I was real good in my little
impulsive paradise,
but then it turns out that I'm just a
halfwit and I noticed that and I want to
do something about it.
So the question is now the question is
has now been posed and what you would
say is the deeper part of yourself,
the part that still contains your
undeveloped potential,
will respond to that posed question and
change the way that you look at things
and changed the way that you act.
It'll start,
it'll start changing things so that you
can tap those parts of yourself that are
not yet developed and you certainly do
that in psychotherapy,
but you can do that.
Young said that psychotherapy could be
replaced by a supreme moral effort and
by that he meant was that if you really
wanted things to be better,
if you want it to get your act together
and you admitted that you were
insufficient in your current state and
you meditated on the issue and tried to
figure out what you should do next to
make to put yourself together,
that you would be able to find out that
there's something in you that guides the
process of development.
That's the self that's a higher.
It's the higher self in some sense.
It's the thing that remains constant
across transformations because you're
somewhere.
Then you fall apart,
then you get somewhere else,
but there's something outside of that
that's guiding that process and that's
also the self.
That's what you could be and you can
communicate in some sense with what you
could be,
and that's a very strange thing about
human beings.
Anyways,
Rafiki shows up and Simba is sitting by
the water self reflecting and there's a
little pebble that drops into the pool
to attract his attention and up pops the
self and Rafique.
He's a trickster.
He tells him weird jokes and he hits him
with a stick a bunch of times.
Thank God because someone really needs
to and he,
he,
he makes some stupid jokes about bananas
and Kinda entices Simba into following
him,
right?
He,
he lets him know that he has a secret
and he entices Simba into following them
and so all of a sudden become interested
in something.
So if you ask yourself what the next
developmental stages and you really want
to know,
then all of a sudden you're going to
become interested in things that might
move you to the next stage.
And that'll happen more or less
unconsciously.
Anyways.
Rafiki entices him and then runs away
and Simba follows it,
and while that's where he reveals
himself as a sage and then he tells
Simba to follow him and he goes
underground,
and this is the initiation scene,
right?
Which we talked about at the beginning
of the class.
This is the descent into the underworld
and it's a.
it's a prerequisite to radical
personality transformation.
So anyways,
he goes through this horrifying
underground tunnel system where
everything's all tangled up,
which is you'll know if you ever fall
into chaos and everything down there and
chaos is tangled up.
It's a tangled mess and he's quite and
there's horrifying music going on in the
background and he goes deeper and deeper
until Rafiki says he finds a pool in the
middle of the chaos,
a deep pool.
That's another symbol of the self.
It's,
it's the deep unconscious.
There's something down there that's
alive that can be drawn up to the
surface.
And so Rafiki shows him the pool and
Simba who's quite terrified at this
point,
looks at it,
and the first thing he sees is he only
sees himself.
He only sees his own reflection.
And Rafiki says,
look deeper now you see what the
animators do here.
It's very cool.
So there's Simba and there's his
reflection,
but you see that is already half his
father and you look at the difference in
the eyebrows and the and the look.
So there's a,
there's a tightness of jaw and a
firmness of face that starting to
manifest itself there.
And that means that he starting to see
the man he could be beyond the
adolescent.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And then all of a sudden while they're,
you know,
that's a whole different face,
right?
That's a seriously different face
that everything's going in and that it's
like get out of my way because things
are gonna happen around me.
Very judgemental as well.
So it's not,
it's not naive by any stretch of the
imagination,
but we know as far as a good guy and so
there's something archetypal about this.
And so he sees the man he could be
reflected back to them and then that
switches that actually becomes a cosmic
event and we switch up to the sky
instead.
And so move fossa manifests himself
basically as a solar deity
and he tells Simba that he's forgotten
who he is,
which is the son of a king,
and that he should remember that and
start acting like it.
And that's an archetypal idea.
So if you're just a useless adolescent,
then you forgotten who you are and the
consequences of that is that the state
is going to fall around,
fall apart around you and you're not
going to do anything to fix it and
you're not going to be good for anything
and no one's going to be able to rely on
you and you're going to be all whiny and
resentful.
And then it after that,
it even gets worse.
And so that's basically what Mufasa
tells them.
And so Simba is like blown away by this
vision,
right?
Because he sees what he could be and
also what he's not,
which is pretty damn horrifying.
So anyways,
the storm,
so to speak,
clears and Rafiki comes up and,
and symbols a lot more thoughtful and
not quite as whiny and resentful
anymore.
And Rafiki
leaves.
And so Simba now knows what he's
supposed to do,
supposed to start
being useless and take on moral
requirements of setting the kingdom
straight.
And so he runs back across the desert,
there's all sorts of impressive music
happening,
and then he comes back to his kingdom
and it's not looking so good and that's
the consequence of his,
uh,
his abandonment of it.
That's a big part of it.
So now it's dead,
but also his abandonment of it to
nothing but malevolence and chaos.
And so
he's pretty taken aback at what's
happened.
And Daddy,
he exaggerates his guilt or it should
anyways.
And nella shows up and,
and they decide they're going to do
something about this.
So in the meantime,
a
sim as mother is complaining about the
fact that there's no food in the kingdom
anymore and that they've gone as far as
they can and scar doesn't want to hear
this.
So he,
uh,
he attacks her and Simba decides to,
to go to war.
And so this is where he wakes up and
he's willing to encounter the shadow at
this point.
And so we confronts scar and scars very
concerned about this because actually
sim is looking pretty impressive now had
he thought he was dead besides and so he
tries to use treachery and whiny ness
and subordination to excuse himself,
but he's planning to overthrow Simba
nonetheless to resist him.
So he tell scar to leave.
He's going to banish him to the nether
regions outside of the kingdom,
like scarred to him.
And scar basically refuses.
And then a storm gathers right and
lights the dead wood around the rock on
fire.
So we have another kind of descended
into hell scene here.
A very common in Disney movies.
This,
this,
this notion of the hero fighting the
evil force on the edge of something
that's burning.
It's quite a common motif.
You see it in sleeping beauty for
example.
So they have a big war and scar ends up
putting Simba in the same position that
Mufasa was in.
And then he whispers to him that he
killed his father.
So Sam has been thinking all along that
it was only his fault and it is sort of
his fault,
but he didn't know that there was a more
archetypal theme playing out in the
background,
which is that societies are always
endangered by malevolence always,
and that's independent to some degree of
symbols,
decisions and his and his lack thereof.
Anyway,
scar tells him to because he thinks he's
won and that energizes Simba to have
this sort of final battle.
He leaps out from the pit and they have
a big fight and he pins him basically,
and the female lionesses come to his aid
and Simba tells him that again,
that he has to leave.
And so they have a big fight that's a
particularly good bit of animation.
So there's real demonic aspect discard
their sort of king of hell imagery and.
But he loses and then ha,
he blames his minions.
He blames the Hyenas for everything
terrible that's happening for getting
that.
They can hear him and then he falls off
the cliff and hygienists go in and
finish them off.
So it's pretty brutal ending for poor
old scar.
I'm eaten by his own minions
and then scars,
Dad and Simba has one,
and so the rains come immediately and so
what does that mean?
Well,
it means that when proper order is
restored in the kingdom,
then everything starts to flourish
again,
and so the rains come and then,
well,
it's raining.
Simba climbs up to the top of the rock
and now he's completely mature,
right?
The facial pathetic facial expression
disappears entirely.
Knee straightens himself up because now
he's full of Serotonin.
After having defeated good old scar and
all the lionesses are roaring and he
climbs up pride rock and they roar at
him,
which is good.
They're tough and he's tough and they
show in their teeth.
It's not.
It's not a society of naive and harmless
creatures.
It's something that's got some bite and
the rains come and then the next thing
you see as the restoration of the
kingdom.
And so basically what that means is that
if the individual is willing to confront
their own shadow and then to take on the
malevolent forces that continually
undermine society,
then harmony can be restored and
everyone can do well.
And so then we have a return to the
beginning,
right?
And so Simba Nela are now a couple along
with Puma and simone,
and they have a baby and Rafiki shows up
and does the same thing.
You know,
he's,
he's got to present the baby to the sun
and have all the animals bow again.
And,
and that's the end of the movie.
So that's all packed.
That's all packed into an archetypical
tail.
And so one of the things that young
would point out is that you all
understood this right while you were
watching it because otherwise at some
level all of these things made sense.
They all cohered and the narrative
appeared to be inappropriate narrative
even when you're a little kid it because
it strikes a chord inside you.
And while that cord,
the thing that it strikes inside you,
that's the archetype.
Because if there wasn't something inside
of you,
so to speak,
that this could communicate with,
then it would fall on deaf ears.
And it speaks to the part of you that's
most particularly human.
And it's a story of the development of
the sovereign individual.
That's,
that's the right way to think about.
So hero archetype,
that's another way of thinking about it
and people are going to get that story
one way or another and now and then a
piece of public art comes along like
this.
That does a good job of encapsulating.
It captures everyone's imagination.
And so that's why you've all seen it.
And why?
I presume you all enjoyed it when you
were kids and maybe still enjoy it now.
So.
Well that was actually faster than I
thought it would be today.
So this is what I'm going to do.
Well,
we've got 20 minutes,
so why don't you think for a minute or
two and I'll take some questions,
which I don't often do,
but.
And they can be any questions about
anything we've covered in class.
So take a minute and.
Yes,
exactly.
Archetype.
Yeah.
Well there's not much difference between
Gandalf and uh,
who's the wizard and Harry Potter
Dumbledore.
There can be the same guy.
That's right.
Right.
And so well that,
that is precisely the indication of the
existence of an archetype.
It's like,
and a movie.
One time a student asked me,
well,
if if there are these archetypes,
why don't we just tell the archetype
over and over,
why do we need fiction,
for example,
which is like a bridge.
If there's individuals here and the
archetype is up here,
you know what a high level of
abstraction fiction sort of fills the
gap between them and so what you want is
a story that's archetipal so that you
understand its basic structure,
but you want enough variation and
specificity so that this new and
interesting and also applicable to you,
so you have to humanize the archetype to
some degree.
Otherwise it's so abstract.
You can't.
You can't relate to it and and good
stories really do that.
They bridge the gap and some of them are
more personal and less archetipal,
but if they're completely non,
there's nothing about them that captures
you.
It doesn't have any force.
And then if it's too archetipal,
well it gets to be too abstract and you
can't relate to it.
So good fiction writers and and good
purveyors of of dramatic entertainment.
We think about it as entertainment are
really good at occupying that middle
position,
so yep.
And they reveal the archetype through
the individual.
That's one way of thinking about it and,
and that keeps it fresh and you know,
one of the things that you pointed out
too was that you're,
you're going to be manifesting
archetypal patterns of behavior in your
life,
whether you know it or not,
we even when you do something like fall
in love,
because that's going to be a very
particular experience for you,
but it's also a very common experience
at the same time.
Right?
And,
and romance is older than people.
That's one way of looking at looking at
it.
I mean,
because sex is older than human beings
and so you're in the grip of something
that's really ancient,
but at the same it's really personal and
so a good novelist or a writer of
fiction is able to capture both the
personal element of that to show the
transpersonal within the personal and so
and in some sense,
your destiny,
proper destiny from a union perspective
is to consciously express an archetype.
And so it'd be the archetype.
There's a bunch of them,
but one of them would be the archetype
of the hero and you're supposed to
manifest that in the conditions of your
own life.
So that makes the archetype real in the
conditions of your own life.
And young would also say that when
you're doing that,
your experience will manifest itself as
meaningful.
And so it's because in some sense you're
acting in accordance with your deepest
instincts,
technically speaking,
right?
You're,
you're acting out what it means to be
human in the world and you're going to
find that meaningful.
So
yes.
Okay.
So the question is about the
relationship between the shadow in the.
Okay.
So
the first thing you have to understand
with regards to trying to come to terms
with the conception of the shadow is to
understand the idea of persona and
persona is the you,
that you present when you want people to
accept.
And like you
often like,
um,
let's say that you go to a party and
you're trying to impress the people that
are there and you're trying to get them
to like you.
And so you maybe get jabbed out a little
bit and you laugh and you know you're,
you go along with everyone so that they
like you,
and then you go home and you're bitterly
resentful about the way that you were
put down at this party.
And that's going to make all sorts of
aggressive.
I wish I could have said it's going to
make all sorts of aggressive and
vengeful,
vengeful thought,
sort of flashed through your
imagination.
Well,
the first part of the problem is that
you are too much persona,
right?
You sacrificed yourself in some sense
out the party so that people would like
you.
And in the second part you're refusing
to admit to the existence of those
elements of you that would have actually
protected you from doing that.
So let's say you go home and you're all
bitter and resentful and you have
fantasies of revenge that reveals to you
the shadow part of you that's
aggressive.
And the thing is you actually need that
because if you would have integrated
that more successfully into your
personality,
when you went to the party,
you wouldn't have had lit.
You wouldn't have had to let people put
you down to get them to like you,
you know,
instead of having a face like this which
says all take anything that's coming my
way,
you know,
you have a face and a stance that's more
determined and assertive and if you
manifest that properly,
people aren't going to mess with you to
begin with,
but you know,
you may have already adopted a morality
that says,
well,
I have to be likable and I shouldn't do
anything that causes any conflict and I
shouldn't ever hurt anybody's feelings.
So you're just present yourself as a
punching bag and you think that that
makes you a good person,
but it doesn't.
And there's no integration of the shadow
in that situation.
So you see that at the end of the movie.
You know when I mentioned this,
when Simba climbs up the rock to take
control of it,
all the female lionesses bare their
teeth and he roars.
It's like that aggressiveness is
integrated into it.
And so resentment is a really good
emotion for making contact with the
shadow side because if you're resentful
about something,
it basically reveals two things.
It either means that you're immature and
you should stop whining and get on with
things you know someone's asked.
This often happens with adolescents who
are asked say by their mother to clean
up the room.
They can all resentful about it.
It's like shut up and clean up your
room.
You know it's.
It's not that much to ask or so.
That can be a gateway into the
observation of your own immaturity or
it's possible that you're resentful
because people really have been poking
at you too much and taking and taking
cheap shots at you end up oppressing
you.
But what that means is that you've got
some things to say that you haven't been
willing to say or don't know how to say.
Right?
You can't stand up for yourself
properly.
And in order to do that,
you have to grow some teeth and be
willing to use them.
And again,
that's something that might violate your
morality because you might say,
well,
I shouldn't be able to bite people,
and the thing is,
yes,
you should be able to bite people hard
and if you're able to bite them,
then generally you don't have to,
but they need to know that you can
because otherwise,
especially people who are badly
socialized,
they'll just keep encroaching on you and
encroaching on you and encroaching on
you and encroaching on you until you.
You put up a wall like someone who's
really well put together won't do that
because they're sophisticated.
But if you run into people who only have
boundaries because other people impose
them on them and you won't do it,
you're going to be the bullied one in
the office for example.
You're not going to get a raise.
People aren't going to credit you with
your own work.
Other people are going to take credit
for it.
You know when you're going to go home
angry because you're doing your best and
you're trying to get along with everyone
and nothing ever goes your way.
Well,
it's because you're a pushover and you
think that's good because you confuse
harmlessness with with with morality.
It's not right.
Just because you can't do any damage
doesn't mean your moral just means
you're.
You don't have the capability for mayhem
and that makes you a pushover,
mean.
The Yoga stuff is very,
very dark.
You know,
it's very dark because his notion of
what constitutes a moral human being is
much different from the typical view.
He really thinks you get that horrible
side of yourself integrated.
So it's up there where you can use it
because otherwise you're,
you're dangerous.
You can't say no to people and you'll go
along with the crowd and then if the
crowd does something particularly
pathological,
which it's liable to do,
you won't be able to resist it.
You won't have the strength of
character.
And so then you'll fall prey to crowd
pathology and it will be because you're
too agreeable with a,
with a shadow resentful side that the
crowd and it's murderous intent is going
to act out.
So
yes.
Yes.
So the question is the relationship
between archetypes,
archetypes in the idea of memes?
Well,
oh yeah,
that's a complicated one.
So Richard Dawkins was the guy who
originated the idea of me and his notion
was that you could produce an idea or a
set of ideas that had the capacity to
propagate across minds for whatever
reason.
It was catchy,
let's say like a,
like a song that gets stuck in your
head,
you know it and that,
those.
He called those memes,
which was sort of a play on the idea of
genes.
So there are these stable sets of ideas
that can be transferred across minds.
Well,
I've often thought when I was reading
Dawkins that if he would've kept
thinking he would have turned into Carl
young because an archetype is a meme,
but it's a really,
really,
really deep meme.
So you could imagine that an idea has
been sold around for so long and that
people have acted out for so long that
it's actually become part of the
landscape that does the selection.
So think about it this way.
So it's more or less a truism that if
you take a male dominance hierarchy,
the probability that the man at the top
of the hierarchy will leave offspring is
much higher than the probability that
the men at the bottom will leave
offspring.
And it's true in many,
many species.
Now there's a much higher probability of
the average female leaving offspring
than the average man.
So,
so now then imagine that there's
characteristics that push a man up,
a dominance hierarchy,
okay?
And then imagine that there are
characteristics that push a man up,
a set of dominance hierarchies so that
each dominance hierarchy has something
in common with all of the others.
It's sort of like the idea of a,
of a good player,
of a game being a good sport across
games.
So then imagine that
the idea of the successful male starts
to become encapsulated in,
in,
in biology,
because the species is going to,
the male part of the species at least is
going to be adapting to the selection
pressures placed on the mail by the male
dominance hierarchy.
So what happens is you have a
competition between men,
the men that win the competition,
find partners and mate so that the male
is going to start to adapt to the fact
of the selection that's implemented by
the dominance hierarchy.
Then you can imagine that that's going
to take case,
take place across dominance hierarchies
because this is happening in many,
many situations spread across time and
so then
the idea of how the proper man should
act starts to become incorporated in the
biology and also in the expectations of
the society.
And then that starts to loop.
So as the expectations become clearer
and clearer,
that notion of what constitutes success
becomes clearer and clearer as well.
And the two things get tangled together.
Now,
and I think you can see that a
manifestation of that whenever you go
watch a movie because you immediately
identify the hero and you identify with
it.
It's like he's the person that you're
mythological imagination grasps onto and
you play that out using your body as a
representational platform when you watch
the movie.
And so maybe you admire the hero.
If he's a successful hero,
you do well.
That admiration is the manifestation of
the instinct that drives you towards
that kind of behavior and not only can
you manifest it,
in which case you're likely to feel good
about yourself because you know that
sometimes you can feel good about
yourself and sometimes not,
but you're also going to be able to
recognize it when you see it in the
world and that's going to manifest
itself in admiration and admiration is
the proclivity Dan imitate
so the meme can be so,
so
you can imagine.
Dominance hierarchies are very,
very old.
They're like 300 million years old.
They've been around a very long time,
and the idea that we have an image of
what it takes to climb the dominant
targets,
it's more or less self evident
because that's the landscape that
selected us,
and at the same time,
you know the,
the archetype,
the pattern that propagates you up.
The dominance hierarchy is also the same
pattern that makes you attractive to
women.
They're the same thing.
So,
and of course that's a massively
powerful selection mechanism and sexual
selection is really shaped human beings.
It's turned us into what we are and
that's an interesting thing too because
you know,
here's one of the things that really
bothers me about the emphasis of
evolutionary scientists on randomness,
so like the the gender mutation
generation process is random or quasi
random.
We don't know that for sure because
there is evidence now that you can
inherit acquired characteristics and
that was nobody thought that was
possible 20 years ago.
So things are have taken a very weird
twist and the Darwinian world.
But for the sake of argument,
we could say that the mutation process
is random,
but the selection process isn't random.
It's not even close to random.
Ever since creatures have been able to
evaluate one another,
the selection process hasn't been random
and so basically were selected by,
you could say by the manifestation of
mind in the world,
unless you believe that women,
for example,
exercise,
no conscious choice in there mate
selection,
which seems completely absurd.
First of all,
men consciously choose who's going to
lead them,
at least in part.
You know who's going to succeed in a
hierarchy and women consciously choose
their sexual partners.
So the idea that the selection process,
that the evolutionary process is random
is it's an absurd proposition.
Sexual selection makes it nonrandom and
Darwin knew that he emphasized sexual
selection a lot,
but more modern biologists since the
time of Darwin,
except for the last about 20 years,
downplayed the role of sexual selection.
And I think the reason for that is that
it brings mind into the evolutionary
process in a way that they don't like
and no wonder it's complicated.
You know,
it's like to some degree we're
consciously directing our own evolution,
at least through the mechanism of
selection.
Yes,
yes.
Well darkens.
Just thought of memes as something that
he'd ever thought about them as
something that could last long enough to
play a role in selection itself.
You know,
he thought about the Morris parasitical
cognitive entities,
I would say that just sort of floated on
the surface of the mental landscape.
He never,
he never grappled with the idea that a
meme could be something that could last
for hundreds of millions of years
roughly speaking.
So
we got time for one more question if
anybody has.
Yes,
yes.
From a political perspective,
like if you divide people by their
political affiliation,
it looks like liberal men are the most
unhappy,
they're higher in neuroticism.
Um,
I think the openness probably
contributes to it as well,
but we don't.
And also possibly the low
conscientiousness when my graduate
students come in,
or one of the many ways we're going to
talk about this in some detail because
she's going to tell you because we've
also looked at the personality
predictors of political correctness,
which is extraordinarily interesting as
well because it doesn't really seem to
fall exactly on the liberal conservative
continuum.
So we'll talk more about that when we
get into the big five part of the
course.
Okay,
good.
We'll see you on Thursday when we're
going to do a speed review of Freud.